Speaker 1: Well, Florida Republican Governor
Ron DeSantis, fresh off of his big win
to reelection in the 2022 midterms,
has announced an investigation into.
COVID vaccines. I know. I know. Ron DeSantis
seems to be going fully anti-vax. We're going
to talk about why he also went on Fox News to
attack COVID vaccines. But first and foremost,
holding a press event yesterday wherein he
announced in conjunction with the Supreme
Court of Florida, they will empanel
a grand jury. Sounds pretty serious,
huh? To investigate vaccine wrongdoing in Florida.
I know, guys. I know it's bonkers what's going on.
Let's take a listen to what DeSantis had to say.
Speaker 4: Because in Florida, you know,
it is against the law to mislead and to
misrepresent, particularly when you're
talking about the efficacy of a drug. We see just
the other. Just recently, Florida got 3.2 billion
through legal action against those responsible
for the opioid crisis. And so it's not like this
is something that's unprecedented. So today I'm
announcing a petition with the Supreme Court of
Florida to empanel a statewide grand jury to
investigate any and all wrongdoing in Florida
with respect to COVID 19 vaccines. And we.
Speaker 1: How powerful, how principled.
Speaker 4: Anticipate that we will
get the approval for that. That will
be something that will be impaneled
most likely in the Tampa Bay area,
and that will come with legal processes that will
be able to get more information and to bring legal
accountability for those who committed misconduct.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Now, listen, there's two sides to
this. One side is, it seems as though Florida may
have committed the misconduct in their opposition,
an attempt to tear down the vaccines, which I
will get to in a moment. But the investigation
really should be. Of those people. Now, you might
remember Florida involved in all sorts of hijinx
with the vaccine. There was the woman who was
putting together that panel to provide COVID
information about hospitalizations, deaths,
etc., etc. She was fired. That was an insane
incident which should be investigated.
They have this state surgeon general,
large head of Department of Public Health, Dr.
Ladipo, or Ladapo, who regularly puts out COVID
and COVID vaccine disinformation as a mouthpiece
for the state that should be investigated. But
that's not what they want to investigate. This
is a point in the pandemic. Where cases are
again going up. The hospitalizations
are disproportionately the elderly.
The deaths are disproportionately the elderly.
We are in flu season. The numbers are not good
for a group that is overrepresented in Florida.
Florida on average, having a significantly older
population than many other states. DeSantis should
be saying, Hey, get your bivalent boosters because
we need the protection right now. But instead,
he announces an investigation into vaccine
wrongdoing. The wrongdoing is the anti-vax people,
the pharmacists who deliberately spoiled vaccines
and the the pharmacies who didn't really vaccinate
people pretended to but didn't actually vaccinate
people. The chiropractor who offered bogus
medical exemptions to be unvaccinated, to remain
unvaccinated fraudulently, and just to anybody who
wanted such an exemption. The people who spread
the disinformation online, some of whom worked for
the state of Florida. That's the wrongdoing we all
know exist. But that's not what Ron DeSantis
wants to investigate. He after this event,
went on Fox News. And that's a whole other
aspect to this, which I want to talk about.
And then we will sort of speculate on why now
and why this. And we'll get to that in a moment.